وامريكا تتجه لاستمالة الصين
وايران تحذر من وصاية امريكية
تقفان في جبهة مشتركة. بوتين
يظهر بقوة كعادته في المصارعة
هي ما تستطيع وقف روسيا. بعبارة
كرر السطر. زلة لسان جديدة
تهدد مجددا برد قوي بشأن كالينين
غراد حذرت وزارة الخارجية
الرئيس ورئيس الوزراء على
الاستقالة. واشنطن وبكين. اجتماع
حرق منزله الى العجب اذا كانت
هذه الثورة بسبب النفط فمن اين
هكذا هرب رئيس سيريلانكا ونجا
بنفسه بالعودة للمحتجين. فهم لم
السياسية والاقتصادية متجذرة في
سيريلانكا لكنها تفاقمت بسبب
الحرب الروسية الاوكرانية
وارتفاع اسعار الطاقة والغذاء.
جوتابايا الذي يقال انه يختبئ في
قاعدة عسكرية سرية. الازمة
رئيسها. العالم اجمع على صفيح
ساخن وليست سريلانكا يا سادة
يقول في اتصال مع نظيره السوري
بشار الاسد ان ايران وسوريا
ان حكومته تدرب الاف جندي
اوكراني على القتال ضمن برنامج
وبريطانيون يمتلكون خبرة تمتد
لسنوات في الحروب الا انهم ولاول
المعارك فقد انسى المقاتلين
الاجانب في حرب العراق وسنوات
الالاف الذين قدموا من مختلف دول
العالم ليشكلوا بذلك الفيلق
العبور الى كالينين جراد بسرعة
فان موسكو سوف تتخذ اجراءات
نصيحة الكبرى ارحلوا. لم يمر يوم
منذ اسبوع من دون قصف. روسيا
التحرش بموسكو ايها الامريكان?
واشنطن اعلنت عن حزمة مساعدات
استراتيجي منذ ثمانين عاما.
واضاف انهينا مهمتنا في العراق
دمج الدفاعات الاسرائيلية مع دول
عربية استفزازية لنا وتهدد امننا
السلاح استعدادا لحرب صينية
محتملة. الا يذكركم هذا بشيء هل
المتبادل. خلال ذلك ظهر مدنيون
تايوانيون وهم يتدربون على
تتذكرون السيناريوهات والتدريبات
الاوكرانية استعدادا لحرب اليست
الدبلوماسية مع بكين ليرد وزير
الخارجية الصيني ان على الصين
قاسية ضدها والاتحاد الاوروبي.
الرئيس الاوكراني روسيا فقدت
نفوذها بالاتحاد الاوروبي. قال
وزير الدفاع البريطاني بن والاس
بالتصريحات لتشن حربها على
تايوان? الاحداث والتطورات. قال
الغزو بايام ما الذي يلوح في
الافق هل تخدر الصين امريكا
حاكم منطقة دونيتسك متوجها
بحديثه الى سكان مدينة سلوفيانسك
العشرين لترد المتحدثة باسم
وزارة الخارجية الروسية ماريا
واضافت انت سيد بلينكن دفعت نفسك
الى العزلة الذاتية. ومن اجل
بعد حصاره ما اضطر الرئيس للهرب
حتى انهم وصلوا الى غرف نوم
تبرير فشلك تختلق القصص. ولفتت
زاخروف الى ان ما يهم الغرب
وامريكا العمل معا لتخفيف التوتر
بينهما داعيا الى الاحترام
تقدم تلك المساعدات راجمات التي
يقول عنها خبراء عسكريون انه لا
الجميع. فكيف سترد امريكا بعد
هذا؟ استفزاز امريكي لبوتين.
كولومبو واخترقوا الحواجز ودخلوا
المجمع الرئاسي يطالبون بتنحية
التدريبات التيوانية شبيهة
بتدريبات الجيش الاوكراني قبل
امريكي صيني في منتجع جزيرة بالي
لخفض التوتر يقول لا بديل عن
على الشرق الاوسط في حين اكتظت
سيريلانكا بالمحتجين وهرب
اليه كي يكرر السطر الاخير مرة
الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي
الروسية لتوانيا من انه اذا ظلت
الامور على حالها ولم تحل مسألة
الشاشة باعتبارها ضمن نفس
الخطاب. ولم يستوعب انها اشارة
لبايدن. الرئيس الامريكي قرأ
التعليمات الموجهة اليه على
نظمته الحكومة البريطانية. زينن
سكي الاسلحة الحديثة والقوية فقط
لهم الوقود لكن ما يجدر قوله ان
الغضب الشعبي هدأ بعد موافقة
يكتفوا منزل رئيس الوزراء
واضرموا النار فيه. نعم لقد تم
دول المنطقة. تناقص فيلق
الاجانب. اوروبا لن تترك
وبحسب التقارير فموسكو تستهدف
مواقع الفيلق اكثر من غيرها. فهل
عاصمة سيريلانكا بعشرات الالاف
من السريلانكيين الى العاصمة
الجحيم الافغاني اكثر المقاتلين
في الفيلق هم امريكيون
اكثر من سبعين عاما. المئات من
المحتجين احتلوا القصر الرئاسي
الاجنبي في اوكرانيا الذي بلغ
تعداده بداية الحرب خمسين الف
بوتين بايدن يتودد للعرب. قال
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن انه
تعرف حقيقة المنطقة وتعمل فقط
على شيطنة طهران وبث الخلاف بين
الرئيس بوتابايا جا باكسا لتسببه
في الازمة الاقتصادية الاسوأ منذ
سيسافر للشرق الاوسط الاسبوع
القادم لبدء فصل جديد وواعد
وزير الاستخبارات الايرانية
اسماعيل خطيب ان زيارة بايدن
ينسحب الاجانب من هذه الحرب?
طوفان سريلانكا. طوفان بشري يغزو
مرة يقعون في الجانب الاضعف
ولاول مرة يقاتلون دون غطاء جوي.
مقاتل على الارض لم يكن دخول
اوكرانيا مثل تركها. اما واقع
القومي وللامن الاقليمي، واضافت
الخارجية الايرانية ان امريكا لا
منذ يوم الحرب الاول. اما زينسكي
فلم يقف متفرجا وطلب الدعم من
وقضينا على تنظيم الدولة في
سوريا. لكن ماذا كانت مهمتكم في
تعني عودة امريكا رسميا الى
المنطقة بمركزية الكيان الصهيوني
الخارجية الامريكي بلينكن يقول
ان روسيا كانت معزولة في قمة
ماذا نقول بل يحاول ويا له من
تحد قد لا يستطيع الغرب الرد
بعد فشل كافة ضد ايران بينما
قالت الخارجية الايرانية ان فكرة
عليه. في غضون ذلك تدور حرب
باردة بين واشنطن وموسكو. فوزير
الاوروبيين بعد ان طالب بالاسلحة
من حكوماتهم. نداء زلينسكي اقنع
العراق يا بايدن قتل اكثر من
مليون عراقي من جانب اخر قال
اوكرانيا لوحدها. لكن الحرب ليست
حرب الناتو. موقف ثابت لم يتغير
اليوم ليس الازمة الغذائية
العالمية ولا الهجرة ولا الطاقة
تفرضها. هناك اكد الرئيس الروسي
ان بلاده لم تبدأ بعد الامور
وتعهدت كييف انها لن تستخدم
الصواريخ لضرب اهداف داخل روسيا.
يمكن لاي نوع من الانظمة
الدفاعية الروسية اعتراضها
عسكريون امريكيون. هايمرز تحقق
التفوق لاوكرانيا. لماذا كل هذا
وطوفان بشري يجبر رئيس سريلانكا
على الهروب بوتين ولماذا سلة
بوتين المتحدي. قالها بوتين في
اجتماع مع اعضاء الحكومة الروسية
الجدية في اوكرانيا فماذا لو بدأ
بوتين بجديته يا سادة. بوتين
جديدة لاوكرانيا باربعمائة مليون
دولار من بينها اربعة انظمة
للدور الامريكي في المنطقة. واكد
بايدن ان السعودية شريك
تجهز عشرة الاف مقاتل اوكراني
فلما كل هذا يا ابناء اليزابيث.
تتناقص اعدادهم في اوكرانيا فكيف
ذلك؟ امريكا تتملق للصين فهل
فعلا في حين تشتعل الحرب الباردة
بين واشنطن وموسكو واستفزاز
باجراءات قاسية فهل تكون التالية
بعد اوكرانيا والمقاتلون الاجانب
امريكي كي يخرج بوتين سلاحا
حديثا. هددت روسيا لتوانيا
تفرضها. يريدون الحاق الهزيمة
بنا. اذا فليحاولوا هكذا قالها
بوتين مؤكدا ان العقوبات تسبب
للغرب ضررا كبيرا. فهل هي كذلك
الولايات المتحدة الامريكية ترسل
معدات عسكرية نوعية الى اوكرانيا
العقوبات على روسيا تسبب المزيد
من الضرر لتلك الدول التي
راجمات الامريكيون يستفزون بوتين
ليخرج اسلحة حديثة. فهل يفعلها
وانما يهمه تنفيذ المقاطعة باي
ثمن كان حتى لو تسبب ذلك بسخرية
يضيف نسمع انهم يريدون ان يلحقوا
بنا الهزيمة في ساحة المعركة.
فالى اين المفر؟
قالت ايران فكيف سيرد الايرانيون
على هذا الاستفزاز؟ وبريطانيا
تستميل واشنطن بكين حزمة امريكية
جديدة من المساعدات لاوكرانيا
جديدة لبايدن فهل اصبحت الزلات
عادة لديه؟ واشنطن تستفزنا هكذا
زاخاروفا. ان بلينكين يختلق قصصا
غير منطقية عن عزلة روسيا.
قيود العقوبات على روسيا تسبب
مزيد من الضرر لتلك الدول التي